Donald Trump's latest non mask visit.
To a PPE factory has led to an entire day's
production of medical swabs being thrown in,
the trash destroyed.
This was on a trip to Maine that Trump did
a few days ago.
He went to Bangor, Maine, Guilford, Maine,
maybe one other spot.
The company he visited is called Puritan Medical
Products.
And among other things, they make sterile
cotton swaps, or Schwabe is, as Trump once
referred to them.
These are sterile, meaning workers wear lab
coats, hairnets, plastic booties over their
shoes, all of that stuff in walks.
Trump with no mask, walks around, talks to
people.
We're showing our audience that's watching
TV footage of Trump walking around, getting
closer to everybody than the recommended six
feet.
And this, of course, raised a bunch of questions.
Hey, this is supposed to be a sterile environment.
And the marketing manager had to admit that
indeed, swabs produced during this time, meaning
when Trump was there, will be discarded.
In their defense.
Or I guess in Trump's defense, they were only
planning a limited production run that day.
In light, I guess, of Trump's presence there.
Puritan is one of only two factories in the
entire country that makes these swabs.
There are still shortages in some areas, even
in Maine.
One third of nursing homes were out of swabs
last month.
60 percent of Maine nursing homes had seven
or fewer individual swabs on hand.
So an entire day's production of swabs in
the trash because Donald Trump, who had to
walk around with that DFAC expression on his
face, uncovered by a mask.
So in the end, maybe the real tragedy is not
they threw out all of that day swabs.
Maybe the real tragedy is that while facing
swab shortages, the entire factory mostly
shut down because Trump was coming to visit
and they produced very little to begin with.
Instead of having a full and real production
day of swabs to get swabs to people who need
them.
But once again, I have to ask, why did the
factory allow Trump to go in without a mask
and without booties on his shoes?
I get it.
He's the president.
But at some point, this has to stop, right?
Like, I would love to see a company just fully
insist.
It doesn't matter if it's the president.
You're not coming in without a mask, period.
No exception.
End of story.
Don't try to bully us.
Just either wear the mask or go somewhere
else.
But at the same time, I do get it because
there's perceived prestige associated with
a sitting president coming to tour your facility
in rural Maine.
People will let him do whatever he wants,
which is the story of his life and they did
here.
I mean, remember, grab him by the you know
what?
That's a story about Trump gets whatever he
wants.
Trump not wearing masks when he goes to places,
even when the production floor is supposedly
sterile.
That's another example of Trump gets whatever
he wants.
That's the story of his life.
And maybe someday a factory or some business
or someone will say it's not happening, my
friend.
It is not happening.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
We are going to talk about how the average
American views police after the last 10 days
of protest.
How is public opinion about police shifted
in the last 10 days?
Number two, South Korea and North Korea are
no longer talking.
And geopolitics experts are worried about
what this might signal for the future.
And lastly, Donald Trump is planning to reestablish
those massive campaign rallies in the next
two weeks, potentially making them super spreader.
Events of Corona virus.
We will talk about all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
join Pacman dot com.
And of course, remember, if you prefer to
consume the show in long form audio format
instead of clips on YouTube, if that's where
you're watching right now, we have a free
daily audio podcast.
The free audio podcast.
It is on I tunes.
It's on Google podcasts.
It's on Spotify.
It's on Pandora.
It's on Stitcher.
Wherever you like to listen to podcasts.
You can find The David Pakman Show podcast.
Get it.
But then become a member.
And we'll see you on the bonus show momentarily.